[Musique]
il fait trop froid pour se changer ici
[ __ ] je suis en retard pour le rallye de maman
[Musique]
vérification de la carte de métro tu as la clé de la maison
ouais
je l'ai eu
allez on va être en retard
[Musique]
hey mec  je remplis tellement ton costume de
neige
est-ce que tu portes toujours ton costume ouais tu
sais juste au cas où
ça irait bien
voir c'est ma partie préférée de vivre
à harlem
pop-up street fair meilleure nourriture de la ville
super
musicien ce serait  super pour la dernière
vitesse sur laquelle je travaillais
je devrais me remettre au mix ouais ça
fait un moment
que pensez-vous de rio morales tu
vas voter pour elle
c'est toujours difficile de penser à maman comme une
politicienne elle a été enseignante toute ma
vie
similaire  jeux de compétences bons grognements les
éduquer
en s'assurant qu'ils ne se lancent pas d'objets
[Musique]
salut je suis brian horton directeur créatif chez
insomniac games
nous sommes ravis de vous montrer ce premier
aperçu du gameplay de merveille spider-man
miles  morales
notre histoire reprend un an après la
événements du premier jeu
et nous trouvons miles new home harlem est en
danger les
ennuis se préparent tandis que miles maman rio
morales mène un rassemblement électoral
une guerre entre la sournoise
société d'énergie roxanne et l'underground
une armée criminelle de haute technologie dirigée par le
bricoleur commence à se briser
dans cette séquence de gameplay capturée sur le
matériel playstation 5,
le métro attaque roxon envoyant
le rallye dans le chaos
dans un combat qui se déverse sur le
pont braithwaite où le métro
tente de voler la
nouvelle forme de source d'énergie expérimentale de roxanne jetons un coup d'œil
ne nous tirons pas dessus  bon,
nous sommes après la nouvelle forme, ignorez
tout le reste
[Musique]
débarrassez-vous de lui puis attrapez autant que vous
pouvez porter
[Musique]
occupez-le
je dois arrêter ces
gens sont piégés là-bas je dois
passer devant  ces gars
où est-il
non
[Musique]
tout le monde sort
merci mec ces gens
ils sont piégés
j'ai une idée
j'ai besoin de quelque chose qu'ils peuvent traverser
je peux arrêter ça
oh monsieur
droite
[Musique]
playstation